So, in this section we are going to talk
about genome assembly using read pairs.
Pavel gave great lectures explaining how
to construct de Bruijn graph from reads.
And from the obtained de Bruijn graph he
explained how to
find an Eulerian path in this graph to
identify the genome.
But he forgot to tell you one important
thing.
There can be
multiple Eulerian paths in the de Bruijn
graph.
Even in this single de Bruijn graph, there
are two Eulerian paths in this graph.
Here they are.
And these two Eulerian paths correspond to
two different strings.
Which string are you going to give to
biologists,
the left one, or the right one, or both?
Please note that
we sequenced only one genome.
Well, this ambiguity
forces us to decompose the de Bruijn graph
into multiple disconnected components.
Each component corresponds to a
non-branching path in the de Bruijn graph.
Please note that while there are multiple
Eulerian
paths in the de Bruijn graph, all of them
share the same set of non-branching paths
shown here.
These non-branching paths in their turn
correspond
to contigs, which are substrings in the
genome.
Well, ideally, biologists would like to
have one contig for each assembly.
Or at least, one should significantly
reduce
the number of contigs. To obtain this goal.
they
invented the technology called read pair
sequencing that I'm going to talk about.
Given multiple identical copies of the
same genome, we now
randomly cut these genomes into large,
equally sized fragments
of size insertLength.
Now for each fragment we generate
pair of reads from both ends of each
fragment.
So now instead of talking about reads
individually, we are talking
about pairs of reads separated by a
distance called insert size.
So, given two k-mers, if they are at a
fixed distance
d apart in the genome, we call them a
paired k-mer.
So the question is, how to construct the
genome, not from the k-mer
composition, like previously described, but
from paired k-mer composition.
But what is paired k-mer composition?
Given a string, a paired k-mer composition
of a string
is a set of all paired k-mers generated
from this string.
Well, because we don't have space, let's
represent a
pair of k-mers as a two-line expression
like this.
Okay?
We can order these paired k-mers in this
order, which is
the order that they were generated from
the genome.
But please note that the position
information is not available.
So a correct way to represent the paired
k-mer
composition should be in lexicographic
order, like in a dictionary.
So the question now is, can you construct
the string
given its paired k-mer composition.
Or let me describe formally.
Input is a collection of paired k-mers.
Output is a string text such that
the paired k-mer composition of text is
equal to the collection of paired k-mers.
How would you solve this?
Let's ask de Bruijn how would he solve
this problem.
Well, I think that de Bruijn would came up
with the same approach
that I am going to describe right now,
which is the paired de Bruijn graph.
Given a genome and its paired k-mer
composition, it's
clear that the genome can be represented
as a path, where
the edges are labeled by paired k-mers,
and the nodes can be labeled by pairs of (k-1)-mers.
And this path, we call it genome path.
But allow me
to do one crazy operation with this genome
path.
Let me glue nodes with identical labels
together.
In this slide, we have two nodes with
identical label, TG|AT.
We glue them.
We glue, and this graph is called the
paired de Bruijn graph from the genome.
Now, you may guess that the next question
I'm going
to ask is, can you construct the paired de
Bruijn graph,
not from the genome, but from the paired
k-mer composition of the genome.
Well, the answer is ..., let's see how we solve
this problem.
Let's represent each paired
k-mer by an edge,
from the paired prefix to the paired
suffix.
Now, let's do the same thing as in de Bruijn
graphs.
We glue nodes with identical labels
together.
Here we glue,
we glue, continue gluing, continue,
continue, continue.
What is it?
This is the genome path,
as if the genome was available.
But it's not all.
We have something more to glue.
TG|AT, TG|AT, they are two nodes
with identical labels.
We have to glue them, we glue.
This is the paired de Bruijn graph from
the read pairs.
Okay, to recap, the paired de Bruijn graph
for a
collection of paired k-mers can be
constructed by two operations.
First, represent every paired k-mer as an
edge between its paired prefix and paired
suffix.
Second, glue all nodes with identical
labels.
In the paired de Bruijn graph, the genome
is
an Eulerian walk in the paired de Bruijn
graph.
But what is the point?
In the de Bruijn graph, we also have this
property.
The genome is also an Eulerian walk
in the de Bruijn graph.
But please note that in the paired de
Bruijn graph, nodes are labeled
by pairs of (k-1)-mers,
while in the de Bruijn graph, nodes are
labeled by just individual (k-1)-mers.
Both of these graphs can be obtained by
gluing operations on the genome path.
But because of the difference in the
labeling, paired de Bruijn
graph is obtained by fewer gluings and
that makes it simpler.
In this case you can see that the paired
de Bruijn graph is simpler than the de
Bruijn graph.
Indeed there's only one Eulerian path in
the paired de
Bruijn graph that allows us to uniquely
construct the genome.
While in the de Bruijn graph we cannot
construct the genome uniquely.
In practice, paired de Bruijn graph has
been applied in assemblers and
it has shown significant advantages in the
resulting assembly.